you you check the mail a few days ago
and what it what envelope did you find
that was addressed to you from the city
of Los Angeles
so jury's jury duty
I got a jury duty letter are you gonna
go No
and also this devote so 44 years of
being alive I've never had one of those
Wow a jury duty letter right because I
don't I want to live on the outskirts of
society mm-hmm you know I also have this
thing where I feel like and this is a
lot of alcoholics and I'm sure a lot of
people with egos have this feeling of
like I feel like normal society rules
and laws don't apply to me like it's a
weird it's a weird way of looking at my
life but it's an honest thing to say
where it's like if I get a ticket or if
I get in trouble I just feel like yeah
that doesn't I'm not a regular kind of a
guy I'm a little different you know me
so that doesn't you know I mean so but
getting that thing you know me I kind of
like that though like he doesn't succumb
to pressure that way like if let's say
let's say for instance like a debt
collector were to harass and call every
day his phone like to me that would get
to me it does get to me and I always
call him back and I'll always be like Oh
what do I owe you know with him he'll
let that [ __ ] ride for five years know
what I do you know what I do
precious is that I I'm not even kidding
you I never answer the phone all my
voicemails are completely full you can
anyb a message right our tactic though
and I just don't I don't bother with
that so it's like an old friend I have a
friend from high school who lives in LA
named Jensen I love him I love the guy I
grew up with him we were in the same
band together in the early 20s bad
laughs and superb you know middle accent
superb you saw YouTube video of him with
really long hair with it well man yeah
yeah and he lives in LA and he calls me
every once a while call him back not
because I don't love them not because I
don't care he's just I just don't bother
with anybody unless it's business yeah
unless it's business
unless it's me because and that's it
though so good about texting me back
like if I never lets it lets my text
wait for more than two minutes at a time
and which is he just Texas to people
he'll he cares about his two things his
work and me my brother maybe
oh yes P for Steve III text back oh yeah
I mean but other than that I don't do it
it's because of the fact that I don't
like the responsibility of being you
know man and I think that's childish on
my part because I don't go to birthday
parties I don't buy Christmas gifts I
only buy Christmas gifts on Christmas
because of her because she does she
cares about Christmas and she has it's
like family a fair thing yeah so I've
been participating not because I want to
I mean I want to I guess but more
because yeah I love kalila and I want
her to be happy
you mean but other than that I've never
done it throughout the history of my
life and I have to understand that like
I can't sit here you know as as his
partner and expect him to fill this role
of average guy who participates in
birthdays and Christmas like in the
beginning I used to think oh [ __ ] like
what did I just sign up for like he
doesn't write a card he doesn't give you
know he just doesn't participate in any
family affairs and I'm such a deeply
like rooted family pipe person because
I'm so I grew up in a really close-knit
large family and but I couldn't hold
that against them in the beginning I was
a little petty and I got to me here and
there but now I've gotten to the point
where I'm just like wait you have done I
have to understand where he's coming
from but he was never raised with
Christmas lights you know he was never
raised without feeling and that warmth
of December 24th and that gathering that
smell of food like none of that it was
no that's that's wrong I thought you
said you did it now you have no [ __ ]
excuse outed by kalila no no we did from
from when I was to tell Polly ten years
old
mhm but something shifted with me
whereas like I told my parents I got
don't do this anymore like I hate it you
mean so it's not because they they tried
my parents trying to
rap shit' and give it to me you mean but
I was always like [ __ ] it
but then I don't understand you anymore
no because the thing is is it to me
it's like you mean what's a gift it's
like you just say I love you to somebody
and that's all and that's enough if you
want if you want to give me money give
me money that's fine but it's it's it's
getting to get it's more than just
telling someone about the getting
together part and your parents you never
really stop to thought think maybe
because you were too young that maybe
what they were doing wasn't all for you
maybe they were doing it for each other
and that that idea that they wanted to
bond with their children maybe they were
doing it for themselves as well like
yeah my dad would get drunk right and
pull my mom's hair through the [ __ ]
living room why he knocked out her tooth
right and my brother and I running for
our lives cuz we're scared shitless yeah
I mean Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
and it had happened at Christmas yeah I
mean it happened randomly on any other
given night right so it's like and I
love the man hmm
I don't blame him you know I mean he did
the best he could
I mean I'm not also one to go all my
life you know these things happen I was
molested you [ __ ] at you know I live in
America I have all this you know I mean
I'm free I could do whatever I want and
I don't you know I just I'm just not
made up that way you know I love I do
love I love you so much and I kind of
love you and you you know I mean but you
know I'm not that's just not me material
yes nothing yeah I'm not I don't really
I care I can't even explain it because
now well I guess all this time I thought
that I was trying to understand you as a
person because you just never grew up
with Christmas and now you're telling me
no it was my choice [ __ ] Christmas [ __ ]
my parents and and now I'm sorry yeah it
was but you have to understand that like
that's still the same thing you know
it's the same exact thing still
I mean it's like it's like you know
because they tried and stopped and
because of my dad's alcoholism it still
tied in with you know I mean that my
Maria yeah like yeah like I don't really
like there was some Christmases where
you know me and my brother would sleep
by the tree
Oh Steve and I and then we'd wake up and
there was a Christmas gift and we would
be like oh my god Santa was here I
remember that you know I mean but then I
also remember like you know man a golf
club being thrown at my [ __ ] ankle
Jesus Christ yeah I mean so it's like
it's all mixed mixed in you know it's a
mixed bag and it's like but I also was a
very bad kid even since I was a little
baby
you mean like I there was this like this
is what's weird it's like when I was a 1
or 2 years old my dad I took these title
that I like these vitamin E it was title
law and I would I ate one just goes on
the table or something and my dad or mom
goes they go don't do that it's bad for
you I ate the whole thing
you're mean Jesus because they said I
shouldn't and then I had to be rushed to
the hospital I had my stomach pumped in
stop oh I just have always had like this
thing or it's like you tell me not to do
it I'll do it anyway don't cross the
street I'll cross don't do that I'll
just do whatever I want
yeah I mean maybe I'm just like a bad
person being your girlfriend is a very
very delicate sport it's a very very
delicate game of what should I say what
shouldn't I say how do I persuade him
you think that the normal way to
persuade someone is just to tell him the
pros and cons or the pros of why you
should do something with Bobby it's not
that way if you want him to do something
basically tell him you have to tell him
that he shouldn't why he shouldn't do it
you shouldn't do it because of this you
shouldn't I'm gonna [ __ ] do it that's
the only reason you get him to do what
he would you need him to do tell him he
should she absolutely he is not allowed
to do it and then he'll do it it's it's
a delicate sport it's a very confusing
sports I'm sorry I'm sorry that you have
to date me I'm sorry that I have all
these problems
sorry okay well you know what he's
really proud of this week you know and
he said to me while I was in the
hospital what um as I was like having an
episode and in the bathroom and those
little pullout [ __ ] and he posted a
picture of me very good picture I wasn't
taking [ __ ] by the way I was when he
peeing but thanks well I on Instagram to
prove that and you know what he said to
me he's leo he said to me what he goes
sweetie do you know how I know I'm not a
narcissist because he said that I posted
a picture without my face in it in the
meantime it's of his girlfriend in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] he goes I am I really
really like sweety and I'm having an
episode he's like sweetie I really do
think I'm growing as a person
and here's proof that I'm not a
narcissist I'm posting a picture of you
my girlfriend and I love you
and did you saw the picture hilarious
sucks for you so maybe he is growing as
a person
anybody's girl through his entire
Instagram to find a picture of of one
but without his face in it and he
couldn't find one so that was his first
one so congrats baby we're growing a bad
person peppers I don't think so
what kind of person do you think I am
like a strong person check out love on
Netflix season 2 coming out next year
[ __ ] you man
anyway you know Prince died and this was
a really weird podcast
[Music]